bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour j mee
merci alors quelques mots d'explication
tout de même pour cette semaine qui
s'entame en raison de l'identification
la semaine dernière deux cas contact ot
coronavirus au sein du personnel de
l'entreprise la direction a été
contraint de modifier l'accès à nos
locaux est donc désormais et ce jusqu'à
nouvel ordre les entretiens dans sa
hotte caddie mais aussi dans d'autres
émissions se feront par téléphone avec
nos invités alors ce matin il a été
annoncé c'est daniel marie-sainte qui
est avec nous par téléphone donc bonjour
daniel marie-sainte bonjour monsieur
métro cayrou vous êtes conseiller
territorial porte parole du conseil
exécutif de la ctm la collectivité
territoriale de martinique
merci d'avoir accepté d'être notre
invité est de répondre à nos questions
et nous allons commencer par part ça
d'ailleurs daniel marie-sainte
l'épidémie de coronavirus nous le
constatons est encore d'actualité
elles marquent fortement depuis quelques
temps la mandature à la collectivité
majeur de notre pays et c'est peut-être
même parti pour impacter encore ces
derniers mois d'ici mars 2021 alors
c'est une situation inédite à laquelle
donc vous et votre majorité
manifestement vous allez continuer
d'être confronté et cela fera
immanquablement parti daniel
marie-sainte du bilan de vos actions que
vous aurez à présenter dans quelques
mois vous êtes comment dirais je
comment vous présentez votre façon
d'aborder cette crise à la fois
sanitaire mais aussi économique et
social d'accord je suis conseiller
exécutif un parent conseiller
territorial quel conseil du cheval ce
sont les membres de l'assemblée le
conseil exécutif bien nous avons dû
faire face si nous avons obtenu d'abord
que le préfet avant de prendre des
décisions ils se concertent
régulièrement avec le prix d'un livre
siel détective parce qu'au début mais tu
peux tenus à l'écart donc il a fallu une
mise au point du président du conseil
exécutif faut que les élus soient prises
en compte
maintenant nous sommes adaptés
d'abord évidemment nous avons suivi le
confinement ce qui a eu quelques effets
de ralentir certain nombre de
nos activités en particulier nos
chantiers le temps que les entreprises
peuvent présenter des plans de
continuité de l'activité
nous nous sommes mis un télétravail en
visioconférence et puis après le
confinement ou au menu en prenant toutes
les dispositions sanitaires ce qu'on
appelle actuellement les mesures
barrières
nous avons repris en présentiel donc
l'activité du conseil exécutif d'une
part mais de la collectivité en général
ne s'est jamais arrêté et puis il faut
dire aussi que l on parle un peu moins
semer les puits d'élèves la porte des
micros vide est doublée en martinique
par l'épidémie de dengue a fait beaucoup
de réglages et le conseil la ctm porte
sa part puisque c'était ma whaap oui les
compétences du conseil général dans la
lutte anti vectorielle d'aller contre
les vecteurs les moustiques qui
transmettent la dengue ministre est donc
le nofollow face à toute cette situation
avec avec des conséquences daniel
marie-sainte temps pour la dengue
d'ailleurs que pour la pandémie
coronavirus des effets quand même très
impactant pour les entreprises des
effets économiques et donc sociaux sur
cet aspect des choses justement vous
continuerez à soutenir les entreprises
du pays
absolument plus que vous savez que dell
annonce des effets évidemment constaté
des plans d'urgence ont été mises en
place et nous n'avons de cesse une fois
évidemment que les votes elle été
effectués dans les deux assemblées que
je rappelle lors d'une une assemblée le
martinique en visioconférence le plan
d'urgence a été mis en place et il est
entraîné les exécuter et puis ensuite
lorsque au mois de juillet la fin du
mois de juillet le gros budget
supplémentaire a été mise en place le
plan de reconstruction comme dit le
président marie jeanne a été actée mise
en place et nous n'avons de celle de
l'exécuter alcool
et nous allons accompagner donc à la
fois sur le plan économique et sur le
plan social
toute l'activité allait autre que le
père mais nos possibilités
il en a coûté combien jusque là pour la
collectivité dans cet effort là bien
tout cas contraire à peu près oui je
rappelle que le 1er place étaient 70
millions et puis ensuite au budget
supplémentaire nous avons augmenté le
budget mais je n'avais augmenter le flux
165 millions du fait que le budget
global de la collectivité qui était de 1
milliard 2 est passé à 1 milliard 4 plus
d'un milliard 4 et c'est cela que nous
n'avons de cesse de mettre l'activité
pour relancer relancer l'activité
pour faire face mais également équipé à
la fois l'eau propre à nos
collaborateurs de toutes les protections
mais également vous savez comme nous
avons en charge les établissements
scolaires lycées et collèges là ça a été
dans les quelques cheveux de s'écouler
l'essentiel de l'activité pour permettre
à la rentrée scolaire de se faire dans
les conditions sanitaires les plus
acceptables
il ya peut-être quand même certains qui
pour estimer que c'est pas à la hauteur
de l'enjeu qu'il faudrait encore
peut-être miser un peu plus face au défi
quand même qu'ils sont importants
vous savez le président apparaît jada
est née surréaliste il y a il peut avoir
la surenchère mais il faut réalise
garder les pieds sur terre et faire en
fonction de nos capacités
si nous voulons garder la confiance le
lot créanciers de nos financeurs il
s'agit le fait à la fois le maximum mais
le maximum possible
alors daniel marie-sainte il ya aussi eu
aussi l'épisode controversé un camp
quand même
il a entendu de la venue d'une équipe
médicale depuis cuba 1 alors ce sur fond
de débat idéologique à propos des
valeurs du système politique de notre
île voisine dans la caraïbe
alors cette occasion à l'esa au sein du
conseil exécutif justement d'autant que
c'est là une initiative un là cette
venue des médecins enfin de toute une
équipe médicale venus de cuba ces
initiatives pour laquelle alfred marie
jeanne
en tant que président du conseil
exécutif s'est personnellement beaucoup
engagé tout de même oui au sein du
conseil exécutif vous savez que le
président le conseil exécutif c'est lui
qui exerce les compétences des relations
extérieures aux nations de la caraïbe
relâché avec l'europe
c'est pour cela qu'il s'est engagé
personnellement bull qui nous représente
aussi bien à l'aller c'est l'association
dit m libre alors qui est ce
à lire également face à la communauté
européenne rup etc
c'est pourquoi il s'engage chez mais en
plus il a répondu à la fois à une
demande des hôpitaux mais également à
une volonté unanime de l'assemblée
il faut se rappeler de ça évidemment
l'escroc se sont fait que les nos amis
qu'hubert la coopération médicale est
parvenu pendant le convient d' mais
était surtout pouvoir répondre à des
besoins lacunaire là où il n'y avait pas
de spécialistes aussi bien au chum sera
hospitalier universitaire quand même la
clinique saint paul nous étions en
carence de très nombreuses spécialités
et d'ailleurs les la composition de la
délégation des médecins qui sont venues
a été fait avec le concours de la rs
alors maintenant il ya des journalistes
venant d'europe qui poursuit qui
continuent à faire leur propagande anti
cubaine et des recettes et des médecins
sur place des médecins d'ici qui
émettent quelques réserves aussi en vous
lavant d'amour pas nous n'avons pas
beaucoup entendu ça puisque très tôt il
a été dit quand il s'agit par les
médecins cubains de venir se substituer
aux médecins de la bâtisse libéral au
contraire j'ai vu un corps médical
hospitalier mais j'adorais de cela et
vous savez que au contraire c'est le
gouvernement français qui a cherché tout
chez le ramier
à la fois diplomatique et peut-être pour
ne pas déplaire à la bière les
américains mais au contraire nous avons
vu des médecins hospitaliers martinique
est qu'ils ont accueilli nous faire
caraïbéen et effectivement nous
souhaitons que cette collaboration cette
coopération s'est sommes déjà au
lamentin avait déjà de la coopération
médicale
c'est le bon sens le les cubains sont
nos voisins de la caraïbe
nous sommes pour la coopération médicale
ils ont développé beaucoup la forme
assure le médecin
nous croyons que c'est un exemple qu'il
faut suivre et c'est pour cela ne nous
sommes en train de construire une
faculté de médecine
dans le pôle universitaire de santé je
sais qu'on n'en parle pas beaucoup mais
il faut savoir qu'actuellement nous
n'avons consultions à côté de l'hôpital
la menace pour l'université de santé où
il y aura une faculté de médecine
une école maïeutique d'adieu le site web
et on va y loger également l'institut de
soins infirmiers
parce que nous sommes en carrosse le
personnel médical ya certains coins de
la martinique
la véritable désert médical donc la
coopération est utile on attendait
entendu il est 7 heures 25 il nous reste
à moins de cinq minutes d'émission avec
daniel marie-sainte donc conseiller
exécutif territorial porte parole du
conseil exécutif de la ctm alors bien
évidemment daniel marie-sainte nous ne
pouvons échapper au dossier de la
canalisation à séguinaud la canalisation
d'adduction d'eau là assez guinot et du
litige avec le propriétaire terrien sur
lequel se trouve une partie de ce réseau
de cette canalisation
alors ça donne lieu à un bras de fer
entre président du conseil exécutif et
assemblées de la ctm y compris peut-être
même son son président de cette
assemblée que le devise
bon ce qui concerne il faut bien le dire
quand même une partie du peuple 1 et qui
pourrait aussi plombé peut-être la
campagne électorale à venir pour le
renouvellement de la collectivité
c'est pas la lettre c'est par la lecture
de jeu niçois de moi de faire maintenant
ah bon voilà une affaire qui a commencé
depuis 2009 et nous avons droit
propriétaires fonciers qui veut
eux se comporter et moi c'est moi qui
dit le terme un profiteur de guerre on
pourra pas faire tout le jazz la elliott
y en a qui veulent s'enrichir nos moyens
en charge le préparer des monges et j'ai
trois solutions de les solutions pour
établir latéralisation passe par
l'acquisition du terrain
eh bien nous sommes prêts à payer le
terrain à sa valeur voilà tout
simplement vous maintenant pour contrer
et vous campé sur cette position
voilà en tout cas c'est le président
marie jeanne qui mène les négociations
dès qu'il me fera savoir que nous avons
la maîtrise du foncier
nous avons à faire des travaux dans
l'habitat voilà avant d'en venir
en quelques mots à au travaux de
l'échangeur de chateauboeuf sur la rn9
on sait que vous êtes beaucoup engagé
sur ce chantier
en quelques mots un correctif quand même
à apporter sur une erreur involontaire
qui a été commise sur notre antenne la
semaine dernière quand il a été question
de l'avenir de l'ex hôtel marouba au
carbet vous savez et que
malencontreusement il a été dit que le
site avait été acheté par la ctm
ce n'est pas exact on le dit là donc on
corrige c'est bien le roi bercy c'est
bien l'établissement public foncier
local le pfl qui en a fait l'acquisition
il ya quelques années alors c'était
c'est vrai sous l'égide enfin le projet
avait été menée par l'ex conseil
régional 1 avant que la ctn soit mise en
place
mais à votre connaissance où en est on
avec ce site à vocation touristique qui
semble bien embarrassant maintenant en
tout cas le pfl levée par le portail du
brochet et faire un appel à candidature
pour trouver des repreneurs viable et
c'est vrai il était prévu dans le
protocole qui le soumet aux élus
régionaux
maintenant c'est lui
la ctfc la cité un manche à un
développement économique et qu'elle ne
soit le projet nous aurons de
subventionner bon je ne suis pas membre
de le pfl l'établissement public foncier
local
il faut s'adresser aux élus glissant
pour savoir pourquoi il n'y a pas de
projets qui sortent maintenant j'ai
voulu rectifier que ce n'est pas dans
notre pratique guad c'est vrai qu'il
était prévu que si au terme de cette
période
cet hôtel départ reprises que le conseil
régional devrait en mousse et le pfl les
sommes engagées
mais nous sommes en attente ne bougeait
très bien le porter de nouveaux projets
voilà on termine sur donc la fin la fin
des travaux mais oui de l'échangeur de
de chateauboeuf sur la rn94 and away we
go après l'effondrement nous avons pu
rétablir sa situation initiale la rn9
mais vaut savoir que nous avons
parallèlement dégagé un consensus
l'avons saisie des tribunaux pour que le
le
droit summa dié que on disait simplement
qui est véritablement responsable de
cette catastrophe pas ça a coûté bien
cher très cher plus de 3 millions à la
ctf c'était déjà prévu met de l'avant
plus gros reproche qui tue est à la fois
le mur de soutènement paroisse pleurer
et l'établi les deux fois deux voies de
la rn 9 et en particulier remettre au
service complet l'échangeur les châteaux
les expertises judiciaires pour
déterminer les responsabilités du
sinistre elle est terminée elle est en
cours elle est encore le tribunal
désigne un expert qui nous rencontrent
les parties et le rapport n'a pas encore
été rédigé merci daniel dory ce sont des
affaires très gros gain non merci merci
daniel marie-sainte d'avoir répondu à
nos questions bonne journée à toutes et
à tous